(audience cheering)
You may have noticed that there was
a few empty seats in the studio.
Let me explain why these seats are empty.
We're celebrating things, New York, this week,
including people who became essential workers
this past year.
That's right.
I love that capes were made and put
on new people, may they forever be there.
It's true, and this past year, one group in particular
that was hit especially hard during the pandemic
were waitresses.
And, my mom was a waitress, and I could see
how her life was so effected by tipps,
and, you know, it just, it gave me a lot
of understanding and respect for that profession.
And, I have a real affinity for tipping
like a baller whenever we can.
That is, thank you to my mom, who like taught me that.
And everybody missed so much, you know,
during the pandemic, especially
something like a dining experience,
which we hold so near and dear.
The pleasure, the memories, the convenience,
the deliciousness, and many of our waitresses
dealt with unemployment and uncertainty,
and we wanted to give back to them.
So, 20 waitresses are actually about
to walk into the studio, they have no idea
that this segment is all about them,
and when they walk in, I thought
we could give them a standing ovation,
do a little clapping, you know,
just, this is their day.
And we're here to honor them.
Oh, I think I hear them coming.
(joyful music plays)
(audience vigorously applauding and cheering)
Turn around! Turn around!
They're all clapping for you!
This whole show is actually dedicated to
and about you guys.
So, welcome to the show, welcome to your show.
We want to honor you, we want to thank you
for what you do in the world.
Everything you have done, everything you've been through.
Everything that you continue to persevere through.
I was just telling our fellow guests here
that my mom was a waitress when I was a kid,
and it just forever impacted my life
to see what tipps mean when you're a waitress.
If there's anyone out there who misbehaves
and doesn't treat you guys with respect,
I would like to just meet them in a dark alley.
(laughs)
I really would.
And I just think that you guys are such incredible heroes,
so we wanted to say thank you, for everything that you do.
(audience clapping and cheering)
I mean, I'd love to hear your experience,
thank you for listening to mine and my mom's,
that left such an impression on me, but,
like, what were some of the struggles
that you went through? Any stories to share?
Yeah! So, when the pandemic started,
I was working at this Caribbean restaurant called "Tilly's"
and when they shut down, is really unfortunate,
I just moved in with my partner,
and, so, all of the sudden I had no income
and they really had to, you know, take care of me
and it really put a strain on our relationship,
especially because she was a registered nurse
going through the pandemic, so,
I wasn't working and she was working over time.
And, thankfully, when Tilly's opened back up,
they rehired me and it really just showed me about
adaptability and, like, rolling with the punches, you know.
Adaptability is something that I believe
in all my heart is one of the most important
character traits that we can attain in this world.
You can adapt, that is a super power.
Becky, I was like, I was wondering,
did you have any social anxieties going back to work?
Like, "yay, we're all together!".
and yet, you're like, "oh, it's so nice to see you".
(laughs)
At six feet, and a mask, and washing my hands fiercely,
like, how was the psychology of coming back,
as great as it was?
Was there any also like, anxieties that came with it?
Yeah, I think, you know, there's a normal part
to have some anxiety coming back,
but once we were in the space,
the atmosphere that was built was just,
people were excited, you know,
we have patrons who've been coming, you know,
for 20 years, and, you know, they know our staff.
We had people even who checked in on our staff every week.
And so it wasn't just, you know,
like this throw you out there, you know, to the wolves,
people were welcoming, people were excited to be there.
And so, that I think eased our anxieties
and we were all being safe.
You know, we all made sure that, you know,
do you feel comfortable? You know, socially distancing,
sanitizing everything and just making sure
that people have that sense of security.
I went to a restaurant last night
and the woman would not let me in,
without my proof of vaccination
on my Excelsior Pass, my guarantee,
I'd keep my mask on and then my driver's license
to confirm that, and I literally, and she's like,
"look, I'm sorry".
And I said, "no, thank you for going these extra steps".
I know not everybody wants to deal with them,
and I'm sorry if anybody gives you attitude
because I'm very grateful for you having to deal
with each step that this is taking.
You're amazing.
Dana, you work at Marie's Crisis.
Oh my God! Which is like,
has anyone here been to Marie's Crisis?
(audience cheering)
Thank you, and, 10 gay men in the back.
(laughs)
It is all about singing and being packed in together.
It is the most beautiful energy and celebration of life.
How is that functioning now?
What's your experience been like?
How do you go from sweating and singing
and being packed in together like sardines,
to the new normal?
Well, at first when the pandemic
and the shutdown happened, our whole staff
decided to get together and go online,
and sing and perform and stay connected,
because we too have regulars who would be there every day.
So we decided to make a Facebook group.
They were amazing, they supported us
and we went from 200 followers to 20,000 overnight.
Wow.
(applauding and cheering)
Thanks!
I just want to thank you for sharing
your incredible stories with us,
and we want to get you guys dinner on all of us.
So we're going to give you a $200 gift card
to some of the best restaurants in New York,
which you're already, you know, working in
and frequenting and our friends
at the American Licorice Company, Red Vines!
They want to tip you guys a thousand dollars each.
(cheering and clapping)
So, thank you, Red Vines! Thank you.
Thank you Red Vines.
(cheering and clapping continues)
Thank you.
Thank you!
There's just something so much better about cash,
you know, it's just so much more instant gratification.
I just thank you so much for being
such wonderful people and keep going out there
and letting us know how we can serve you.
(joyful music plays)